[Music]
surprise
taylor swift dropped her new album
folklore late
thursday night ah it's it's just
unbelievable
now a slew of dedicated swifties are
pretty much
convinced her boyfriend joe alwyn was a
secret co-writer
on some of the songs songwriting has
always been the number one
thing the writing aspect of it if i
didn't write i wouldn't sing
here's why on thursday morning when tate
hit up instagram to announce she would
be dropping a surprise eighth studio
album at midnight
she thanked songwriters aaron destner
jack antonoff
bonavere and someone named william
bowery
fans were quick to notice that this
william guy was the only person on the
list
she didn't tag and let's just call her
fans
sherlock freaking homes because they
discovered
that there are no registered songwriters
or producers
named william bowery these are things
that make me break out in a full body
sweat
now going off the theory that william
bowery is a pseudonym for someone else
taylor's fans did what taylor fans do
and went
digging i love a challenge turns out
according to some paparazzi picks
taylor and joe were spotted outside the
bowery hotel in new york city
back in 2016 for the start of their
romance
then fans searched the actor's wikipedia
page which reveals he is the great
grandson of
english composer and musician william
alwyn
therein lies the theory that william
bowery
is actually joe alwyn
i don't even i can't so why hide her
boyfriend's identity
why not the singer has been known to
plant easter eggs for her fans and the
girl
loves her a hidden clue in fact she even
told her fans that for folklore she put
easter eggs in the lyrics and
not just the music videos so while it's
not necessarily confirmed that joe
contributed on the album
the theory does have its fair share of
circumstantial evidence
i think for me it's uh really important
to constantly challenge yourself
and also i think you have to
keep people's attention by surprising
them and
the ways in which i like to surprise
people are with my creative choices i'm
not much into shock value
in other aspects of my career but as far
as my musical direction goes i would
always like to
keep people on their toes in that regard
i think that's the best way to be
[Music]
exciting
you